[Música]
pese a los choques entre manifestantes y
la policía y a un nuevo fallecimiento en
Arequipa la presidenta de Perú Dina
boluarte aseguró que la situación está
bajo control y reiteró su llamado al
diálogo esto mientras que miles de
ciudadanos protestaron en la capital
peruana durante la toma
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
pidió Investigar las denuncias de abuso
sexual contra menores indígenas en el
departamento de guaviare en el Oriente
del país presuntamente a manos de
militares al menos 69 casos fueron
revelados en una investigación
periodística lo que ha generado fuertes
críticas ante la inacción de las
autoridades tenemos análisis
el presidente Joe biden viajó hasta el
estado de California fuertemente
golpeado por las incesantes lluvias que
dejaron Al menos una veintena de muertos
y graves inundaciones en varias ciudades
el mandatario anunció ayudas adicionales
y señaló que la peor parte ya pasó
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Perú donde se registraron fuertes
choques entre manifestantes y la policía
durante la toma de Lima miles de
personas protestaron en la ciudad
exigiendo la renuncia de la presidenta
Dina boluarte y condenando la represión
en las manifestaciones tras la
destitución de Pedro Castillo a nivel
nacional al menos 18 regiones se vieron
afectadas y tres aeropuertos cerrados
además se presenta un nuevo
fallecimiento
pese a lo ocurrido la presidenta Dina
boluarte aseguró que todo se encuentra
bajo control y añadió que las acciones
violentas de algunos ciudadanos no
quedarán impunes
el gobierno está firme y su gabinete más
Unido que nunca nuevamente
llamó al diálogo
llamo a la calma
a aquellos líderes políticos
que están llamando a estas marchas de
protesta
tengan una mirada de país más sincera
más objetiva
más hermanada
y conversemos y dialoguemos todo el
rigor de la ley caerá sobre aquellas
personas que están cometiendo estos
actos delincuenciales de vandalismo que
no lo vamos a permitir continuamos en el
Oriente colombiano porque el presidente
Gustavo Petro anunció medidas urgentes y
pidió Investigar los abusos sexuales
presuntamente cometidos por militares
contra al menos 69 menores indígenas en
el departamento de guaviare la
información Se conoció a partir de la
investigación del periodista Gerardo
Reyes de Univisión ha generado una
fuerte condena contra la fiscalía que
catalogó las denuncias de falsas y
contra la inacción del instituto de
bienestar familiar según datos oficiales
hay casi 600 casos entre 2018 y 2020
solo en ese departamento previamente
conversamos con Laura Márquez Ramírez
investigadora de la organización cisma
Mujer en Colombia que nos habló de la
realidad de la explotación sexual en
guaviare por un lado estamos ante una
situación de subregistro de
se sabe que las comunidades indígenas y
especialmente las niñas y las mujeres
enfrentan condiciones históricas y
estructurales de desigualdad de
discriminación de pobreza además de
inseguridad alimentaria y de violencias
es decir en términos generales no hay
una garantía de derechos y esto supone
riesgos diferenciales las niñas son
Víctimas de violencia sexuales
y además pues no pueden denunciar
usualmente las denuncias se adelantan
por personas mayores
y frente a esta situación cuál es la
respuesta del actuar del Estado las
denuncias de violencia sexual en contra
de niñas en el guaviare incluyen a
miembros de la fuerza pública que han
sido señalados como presuntos accesorios
en este sentido la presencia de
militares supone en lugar de un factor
protector un riesgo para las niñas los
niños y las mujeres del departamento
vamos a Estados Unidos porque el
presidente Joe biden visitó el estado de
California para inspeccionar los daños
causados por casi un mes de constantes
lluvias las cuales dejaron graves daños
materiales y 20 personas muertas durante
la visita el presidente fue interrogado
sobre el escándalo de los documentos
clasificados del cual ha sido blanco los
últimos días Andrés triviño tiene los
detalles En búsqueda de la
reconstrucción el presidente Joe biden
visitó el estado de California para
inspeccionar los daños causados por casi
un mes de lluvias incesantes que dejaron
ciudades bajo el agua miles de hogares
en electricidad Y al menos un veintenar
de Muertos
si bien la situación sigue siendo
traicionera somos cautelosamente
optimistas de que la peor parte ya pasó
las aguas retroceden pero veremos el
alcance total de los daños a los hogares
los negocios y las granjas y ranchos
un fenómeno conocido como río
atmosférico produjo tormentas
torrenciales a un estado que está
acostumbrado a sufrir sequías casi
perpetuas así como se ve en esta
comparación de imágenes satelitales
biden prometió una ayuda adicional a los
9 millones de dólares que ha dado su
gobierno a California para hacer frente
a las emergencias climáticas no podría
estar más agradecido con el presidente
por tomarse el tiempo de venir
nuevamente al estado de California para
ver de primera mano los daños durante su
visita el presidente fue interrogado
sobre el escándalo que los salpica desde
hace unos días luego de que se
encontraran documentos clasificados en
su residencia privada
descubrimos algunos documentos que
habían sido archivados en el lugar
equivocado inmediatamente los entregamos
a los archivos nacionales y al
Ministerio de Justicia estamos
cooperando plenamente y Esperamos que
este asunto se resuelva rápidamente
el asunto está afectando al presidente y
a sus funcionarios quienes han dicho que
actuaron de manera rápida y adecuada
cuando se descubrieron los documentos
aunque las preguntas clave Siguen sin
respuesta
continuamos en Estados Unidos porque el
actor Álex Baldwin fue acusado de
homicidio involuntario por el tiroteo
durante la filmación de la película rust
ocurrido en 2021 la fiscalía pedía dicha
imputación al asegurar que el actor
debía haber revisado que el arma no
estuviera cargada en octubre de 2021 la
directora de fotografía de la película
murió después de ser herida por un
disparo durante la preparación de una
escena faldn estaba apuntando con la
pistola Hopkins cuando se disparó
matándola e hiriendo al director Joel
Sousa
el cofundador de Netflix ready hastings
anunció que dejará el cargo director
ejecutivo y entregará las riendas del
servicio de transmisión al socio y
codirector ejecutivo text sarandos y al
director de operaciones de la compañía
Greg Peters sin embargo se mantendrá
como presidente ejecutivo
hastings hizo su salida cuando Netflix
anunció 7,66 millones de nuevos
suscriptores en el cuarto trimestre de
2022 superando las previsiones de Wall
Street de 4,57 millones con la ayuda de
Harry Megan y Merlina en la batalla por
atraer nuevos usuarios las acciones de
la empresa que habían caído casi un 38%
el año pasado subieron un
6,1%. Netflix lleva meses bajo presión
luego de perder buena parte del mercado
en la primera mitad de 2022
el presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva se mostró decepcionado
frente al papel de los servicios de
inteligencia el pasado 8 de enero día en
que seguidores bolsonaristas atacaron
las sedes de los tres poderes el
mandatario aseguró que quisiera tener
una relación civilizada con las fuerzas
armadas pero resaltó que lo más
importante es no politizarlas
no tuvieron el coraje de hacer nada
durante la toma de Posesión cometimos un
error elemental mi inteligencia no
existía salí de Brasil y el viernes con
la información de que 150 personas
estaban acampando y todo estaba
tranquilo que no dejarían entrar a más
personas y que no permitirían que se
reunieran más personas viajes a Sao
Paulo con la mayor tranquilidad Y
entonces Esto fue lo que pasó
tenemos muchas inteligencias aquí
tenemos inteligencia del ejército
inteligencia de la fuerza aérea ninguno
de ellos me advirtió
el ejército colombiano rescató a un
dominicano que llevaba 24 días perdido
en el mar Caribe en Un velero la pequeña
embarcación fue divisada desde el aire
con la palabra ayuda escrita en el casco
en ella estaba Elvis françois un hombre
de 47 años que fue arrastrado al mar
cuando repa el aparato en la isla de San
Martín Elvis dijo que sobrevivió
comiendo una botella de salsa de tomate
ajo en polvo y una botella de sazonador
que encontró en el bote
la población de iguanas amarillas en la
isla fernandina de Galápagos ha
aumentado a 46.000 especímenes una buena
noticia que entregaron las autoridades
del Parque Nacional Galápagos el aumento
en la población de especies endémicas se
logró a través de un programa de
conservación permanente llevado a cabo
dentro de la tercera Isla más grande de
Galápagos tener una población grande y
saludable de iguanas amarillas es bueno
para el ecosistema porque ayudan a
esparcir semillas por toda la isla
además se trata de una especie
catalogada como vulnerable por la unión
internacional para la conservación de la
naturaleza
así llegamos al final de esta
informativo pero ustedes Les agradecemos
su sintonía les recordamos que pueden
ampliar todo nuestro contenido en la web
France 24.com quédense con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]